wir geben dem bundesheer eine struktur
die den neuen budgetären
rahmenbedingungen rechnung trägt dabei
muss die armee auch in der neuen
struktur in der lage seien militärisch
einsatz wahrscheinliche aufgaben zu
erfüllen
aufgrund der massiv eingeschränkten
budgetmitteln wird es darum
schwergewichte geben die sich
weitestgehend an diesen bereichen
orientieren
unterm strich heißt das dass wir bei
unseren landstreitkräften in zukunft auf
die waffengattungen infanterie
spezialeinsatzkräfte pioniere und abc
abwehr truppe konzentriert werden die
miliz wird deutlich gestärkt bis 20 18
werden wir zwölf zusätzliche miliz
kompanien aufstellen
unser konzept hat ein gesamtvolumen von
rund 200 millionen euro pro jahr das wir
einsparen werden 19 und das zeigt auch
wie wichtig uns die miliz ist dass jedes
material zumindest eine miliz company
haben wir in zukunft die zentralstelle
mit einem ersten schritt jetzt beginnend
um 15 prozent reduziert jedoch in einem
sehr mitarbeiter verträglichen weg
werden alles tun dass die einsatz
wahrscheinlichen aufgaben die
angesprochen worden sind von
katastropheneinsatz bis zum
auslandseinsatz weiter erfüllt werden
können
wir werden alles tun um die wehrpflicht
reform durchzuführen und vor allem wir
brauchen ausbildungskapazitäten die wird
derzeit nicht haben die müssen wir
aufbauen
wie geht es jetzt konkret weiter die
notwendigen vorarbeiten
seitens des ministeriums sind mit dem
vorliegenden konzept geleistet
die erforderlichen politischen gespräche
mit dem koalitionspartner sind im laufen
unser ziel ist es diese neue struktur
bis 20 18 auch tatsächlich eingenommen
zu haben
diese einschnitte sind für das gesamte
ressort schmerzhaft aber zugleich der
einzige weg die handlungsfähigkeit und
die einsatzbereitschaft des
österreichischen bundesheeres aufrecht
zu erhalten